et nous retrouvons maintenant sans plus
attendre yann wehrling l'invité de
samedi politique
il vient d'être je vous le rappelle
désigné chef de file et non pas tête de
liste du modem pour les élections
régionales en ile-de-france alors pour
commencer daic son portrait avec un
petit fond de verre dessiné nous yann
wehrling ça tombe bien parce qu'il est
dessinateur à la portrait en animation
graphique apparaît parnas millagou remy
c'est parti à l'organe wehrling vous
êtes un homme rare attention rares ne
veut pas forcément dire précieux la
rareté c'est que vous êtes conseiller de
paris élu modem
alors ok je suis pas très gentil la
vraie rareté c'est que vous venez de la
gauche et que vous avez même dirigé les
verts et oui vous étiez là cécile duflot
dans les années 2000 et deux ans
seulement la tête des verts
bah ça suffit pour vous vieillir bien
avant l'âge car c'est fatiguant mais
vous êtes refait une santé auprès de
françois bayroux séduit par son discours
qui veut dépasser les clivages partisans
alors ça ça marche bien pour la
présidentielle mais entre deux campagnes
pour l'élysée faut bien se présenter aux
élections locales est pas facile pour le
modem qui n'est pas assez puissant pour
exister tout seul alors vous serez le
chef de file du modem aux élections
régionales en île de france
mais avec quelles alliances allez-vous
rejoindre vos cousins centriste de l'udi
ou directement l'ump de valérie pécresse
ou alors avec tout le monde ensemble
dans un ménage à trois de circonstance
un trouble comme on dit quand on veut
faire moderne maintenant ça vous a fait
rire yann wehrling de vos bras que la
tête de cécile duflot
ouais ouais ouais c'est amusant cécile
est est quelqu'un avec qui j'ai gardé
quelques contacts et bon elle a un
parcours qui le sien j'en ai un autre
verre je suis bien à corriger un tout
petit pois je viens pas de la gauche je
viens de l'écologie et j'y suis toujours
je suis toujours encore écolo mais j'ai
toujours été un écolo centriste et
d'alerter un peu la gauche
à bas les jeux c'est pour ça que j'en
suis parti c'est trop à gauche mais moi
je les colle au centre et au modem et on
a appris cette semaine que vous seriez
chef de file pour les élections
régionales en ile-de-france on le savait
mais il ya aussi marielle de sarnez est
ce que ça veut dire que marielle de
sarnez est candidate et sera candidate
aux régionales en île de france m
marielle de sarnez a conduit comme vous
le savez une liste aux européennes a
fait un excellent score
elle incarne le centre en ile de france
et même au delà
et c'était absolument nécessaire qu'elle
s'implique dans cette élection
et moi j'en suis très content mais
qu'est-ce qu'on va dire si elle est
candidate elle est déjà députée
européenne conseillère municipale de
paris on a l'impression modem il ya
qu'elle en ile de france et que vous la
sortez à chaque fois parce que vous avez
personne d'autre mais non elle incarne
incarne le centre elle est vraiment une
personnalité importante
moi je m'implique aussi dans ces
élections régionales à ses côtés avec
elle on va faire un binôme et et moi
vous la vie doute fait leur jet incarne
une sensibilité écolo elle l est elle
incarne le centre c'est quelque chose
très complémentaire et qui va être à mon
avis intéressant de cette campagne est
ce qu'elle sera candidate balle va faire
équipe avec moi bien sûr aux anneaux
qu'elle serait candidate
oui vraisemblablement alors qu'elle a
déjà deux demandeurs uniquely cumularde
franchement pour le modem qui veut
prétendre à des nouvelles pratiques
politiques plus moderne plus
démocratique
voilà elle est candidate à toutes les
élections en ile-de-france marielle de
sarnez
oui mais quand vous êtes qu'on fait de
la politique vous impliquer c'est
absolument nécessaire vous pouvez pas
comme ça papillonner donc marielle est
pleinement impliqué et c'est c'est
quelqu'un sur qui on compte beaucoup et
moi je compte beaucoup sur elle pour
cette élection régionale et je pense que
ça va être bien mais elle est appliquée
parce que vous manqué peut-être un peu
de ténors et de personnalités un peu qui
sortent du lot par ait parlé de rareté
tout à l'heure moi je suis pas d'accord
parce que vous avez on a d'abord dans
cette élection régionale en as to know
to me députés européens qui sont
impliqués d'une certaine main c'est
aussi un message parce que vous avez
dans le discours qui est le nôtre deux
de grandes de grande implication qui
sont ils l'implication pour l'europe et
l'implication pour une région forte pour
des régions fortes mais l'europe les
régions tout ça ça va ensemble et et
c'est aussi ça la logique qui avait
prévalu d'entre dans les désignations
des chefs de file
mais a priori vous ne souhaitez pas
présenter une liste indépendante parce
que vous êtes plutôt petit donc vous
souhaitez des alliances alors est-ce que
vous allez on nous dit que l'alliance
avec les cousins de l'udps et les
cousins centriste elle est automatique
or ça l'a coincé en ile de france c'est
pas que ça coince et que chaque chose en
son temps je vais vous dire moi la
politique de manière générale je la
conçois avec une priorité absolue c'est
de dire pourquoi on y va quelles sont
les idées qu'on a envie de mettre en
avant et c'est ce temps là qui est le
nôtre aujourd'hui c'est comme on descend
décoller en ce moment avec chantal
jouanno qui est la candidate de l'union
régionale en ile de france mais avaient
pris contact avec elle vous êtes en
train de réfléchir si vous allez faire
des listes avec elle encore une fois je
vous dis que moi ce christ qui
m'intéresse aujourd'hui ce qui nous
intéresse aujourd'hui
travailler à ce qu'on a envie de dire
aux franciliens aux idées qu'on a envie
de porter à cette région qu'on a envie
de changer
raismes des choses extrêmement
problématique dans cette région sur
laquelle la région a des choses à dire
améliorer les transports
bye bye le rire oui si vous voulez
mettre en place vos idées faut être élu
pour être élu il faut que vous alliez
avec quelqu'un faire une alliance avec
lui dit vous avez raison de dire dans
quel ordre il faut faire les choses
- l'ordre que j'imagine et c'est l'ordre
normal de la vie politique c'est d'abord
on dit qu'on y va ensuite on dit ce
qu'on propose
et ensuite on garder stratégie r ce que
vous notez leurs alliés avaient claqué
pas notre calendrier aujourd'hui de les
discuter de ça notre calendrier
aujourd'hui c'est à dire quelles sont
nos idées et à l'échéance de l'été on
verra castres exige en tout cas nous on
est pour des rassemblements larges c'est
sa respiration dix ans vous vous
souhaitez en fait une alliance ump udi
modem au premier tour
ce que je souhaite et ce que nous
souhaitons c'est de faire en sorte que
les idées qu'on va porter puisse gagner
demain donc on va choisir la stratégie
qui va être la plus gagnante
bien évidemment mais ça ça se décidera à
l'été encore une fois ne précipitons
rien ne vous avez dit quelque chose
aussi qui est de l'ordre de la petite
politique de parti et je suis pas sûr
que les gens aient très envie d'en temps
ils ont envie d'entendre aujourd'hui ce
qu'on propose
et nous c'est ce qui aujourd'hui est le
plus important est pensé dans les
appareils jean noël on sait qu'il ya des
discussions en ce moment vous souhaitez
quand même une alliance eu des ump modem
plus qu'une alliance sud et modem seul
et comment il se retrouve les électeurs
là dedans ce que recherche le centre
désespérément sais pas si c'est plutôt
sur le centre-droite centre gauche ou
carrément la droite
j'ai la faiblesse de penser que les
électeurs ils ont envie de savoir ce
qu'on a envie de proposer pour cette
région à savoir avec qui on va le faire
enfin je suis désolé mais je sais que ça
vous intéresse je sais beaucoup de gens
dans ce dans le microcosme politique
s'intéresse essentiellement cette
version a l'air un peu pâle ils
viendront en leur temps
encore une fois aujourd'hui moi j'ai
envie de vous parler des sujets qui moi
me préoccupe pour la région
ile-de-france les choses qui me met en
colère par rapport à la situation de la
région ile-de-france alors très vite sur
les transports est ce que tous les
candidats vont proposer bas il faut des
transports qui marche mieux qu'ils
soient un peu plus à l'heure qu'ils
seront un peu plus moderne
oui mais il y en a qui seront plus ou
moins crédibles pour le dire ou tout du
moins entendable parce que ceux qui sont
au pouvoir depuis 17 ans or les gens de
religions principalement qui va le dire
que d'ailleurs dit l'autre jour que les
trains arrivent à l'heure enfin il les
prend jamais donc voyez bien qu'il ya un
décalage ya une déconnexion aujourd'hui
des équipes qui n'est saisie de
l'échangé ses équipes alors déjà fait un
premier point qui peut répondre aussi à
votre dernière
question c'est on veut un changement
d'équipé alors région d'île de france
pour faire justement des choses
nouvelles et aussi mettre en place des
gens qui ont peut-être la clairvoyance
de ce qui se passe réellement dans la
région et qui ne sont pas embrigader
enfermés dans leur région sans avoir vu
ce qui se passe depuis 17 ans voilà donc
ça c'est un point essentiel les les
transports en ile de france ça ne marche
pas c'est pas à l'heure moi je prends
régulièrement le rer que soit le rer a
où le rer b
c'est un scandale là mais les voilà tous
les candidats devront déposer
finalisation et on sait que ça dépend du
stif qui dépend aussi quand même pas mal
de la ratp sncf difficile à faire bouger
ne démissionnons d'aucune manière les
choses se décident par les politiques
et si on n'a pas mis en place les bonnes
structures pour décider on va changer
les structures
s'il ya une confusion des esprits entre
qui doit décider quoique à la fin des
sites pour rien il faut changer ça et on
a cinq ans pour le faire on aura le
mandat le prochain mandat pour le faire
eh bien il faut qu'on soit extrêmement
proactif pour changer les structures si
c'est ça qui ne marche pas allez on va
parler de d'anne hidalgo célébrer ou
fêter je sais pas encore mais on doit
dire les à nantes sa mandature puisque
vous êtes également conseiller de paris
donc comment vous jugez c'est un an de
mandature
anne hidalgo a beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup communiqué et le résultat n'est
pas là bas écouter sur un sujet qui me
tient à coeur la pollution de l'air très
honnêtement les pics de pollution on en
a de plus en plus souvent alors qu'elle
ne vienne pas nous dire qu'elle a fait
tout ce qu'il fallait d'abord palais pas
là au pouvoir depuis un an elle est là
au pouvoir depuis bien plus longtemps
que ça ça fait pressant que premier
adjoint
tiens en tant que responsable totalement
qu'elle n'assume rien du mandat
précédent où elle était première
adjointe fait quand même pas rien n'est
de première adjointe
non moi je sais tout ça c'est du ccd
rigolade elle était au pouvoir depuis
dix ans depuis plus de dix ans et il
s'est rien passé en matière
d'amélioration de la pollution de l'air
au contraire s'empire mais ce que je
veux vous dire et c'est en lien avec la
région
c'est qu'à un moment donné il faut
savoir prendre consciencede à quel
niveau il faut agir et comment il faut
agir et on ne peut pas régler le
problème de la pollution de l'air si on
ne règle pas à l'échelle justement de
l'île de france
nous ça fait des semaines ça fait des
mois ça fait depuis qu'on est élu au
conseil de paris qu'on demande un
grenelle de l'air qui mettent autour de
la table tous les responsables
politiques à l'échelle de l'île de
france et c'est ça qui va régler le
problème en partie pas tout voir en vo
la france parce qu'après il c'est une
question de frontières donc lé fonds
tire lait de france thème de la
pollution c'est de mettre autour de la
table tous ceux qui ont parti prenant
dans la décision y compris l'état
justement l'état l'état qui doit nous
mettre en place la bastille vers qui va
permettre à des reculs prof de pouvoir
circuler dans paris les jours il ya des
pics de pollution aujourd'hui ses pairs
un père c'est absurde
donc demain il faut favoriser les
véhicules les plus les moins polluants
un mot sur les autocaristes et l
actualité oui les temps il manifesté
puisqu'ils sont contre les hausses de
stationnement c'est la première effets
de la politique anti pollution de madame
hidalgo c'est d'abord les autocars
d'abord c'était l'été puis après ça
serait les véhicules individuels qui
seront polluants c'est une bonne
politique ça paraît bah disons que les
efforts moi je suis un tollé qu'il va y
avoir des crispations par rapport à
l'est des mesures qui ont été prises il
fallait prendre des mesures de distinguo
entre les véhicules polluants et les
moins polluants pour pouvoir circuler
dans paris quand y'a de la pollution et
même de manière générale maintenant il
faut vraiment aussi avoir une politique
d'accompagnement on peut pas tout
interdire sans accompagner les gens et
les les professionnels et les l'économie
qui en dépend on sans se soucier des
conséquences est là anne hidalgo de ce
point de vue là a été un petit peu sans
méfiance par rapport à la sont prudents
par rapport à la capacité de faire en
sorte que et bien il ya un mouvement de
dire d'abord la carotte et après le
bâton elle a mis le bâton d'abord il ya
pas la carotte et ça ça peut poser
problème et faire des crispations et des
retours en arrière il ya quelques jours
une dizaine de jours a déclaré que les
conseillers parité trop payés c'est un
peu plus de 3000 euros par mois
donc vous êtes trop payante en conseil
de paris vous fait quoi de l'argent que
vous estimez recevoir en trop oui je
sais vous alimentez de populisme et la
démagogie
non à chaque fois qu'on dit qu'un
politique met le doigt sur un problème
on va dire qu'il va falloir résoudre à
l'avenir qui est leur relation du
politique à l'argent le cumul des
mandats j'endure chaque fois c'est
démagogie non amende il faut dire les
choses avec honnêteté avec sincérité je
me suis pas fait que des amis en disant
ça mais j'ai quand même dit une chose
qui est vraie c'est qu'à un moment donné
il faut être dans la mesure par rapport
à aux moyens dont disposent les élus
efforts d'argent merci photo yann
wehrling d'avoir été notre invité merci
beaucoup daic